comme toi explique un jeu
jana
sa connectique shekhar dont elle mettait
pourtant
vous allez peut-être découvert la vie de
lorie et demi à l'aine sur la colline du
crack dans une vidéo que j'ai réalisés
précédemment pro brut du souvenir en
france à l'âge de 10 ans mahmoud abbas
et le groupement familial pour moi donc
ça m'a toujours posé des problèmes aux
fermes et papiers les gens qui ont fait
douter de la drogue
je pensais qu'avec 16 à l'oublier mais
sous signe pour les messins valeur
ajoutée
[Applaudissements]
quelques semaines après cette vidéo j'ai
retrouvé laurie elle est rentrée chez sa
mère en belgique
laurie est enceinte et a complètement
arrêté le krach la chaussée
depuis le démantèlement de la colline du
crack
je n'avais plus de nouvelles de merlen
et vous étiez nombreux sur les réseaux
sociaux amendements des gelées
finalement retrouvé près du canal de
l'ourcq à paris autre lieu de
rendez-vous des consommateurs de crack
me allen a accepté de me raconter son
histoire
et comme lori de la drogue est arrivé
dans sa vie pour tenter d'oublier un
passé douloureux
il ya plein de gens qui demandent des
nouvelles sur internet tu peux nous dire
où tu emménagés les remercie beaucoup
il pose à moi oui - ah oui petites
mimines alors tu n'as qu'à leur dire que
je les remercie beaucoup et que je j'ai
fait tout ce que je peux que ça et mieux
ça me fait bizarre que déjà il faut
savoir c'est rare ceyrac et des heures
il faut simplement personne aussi j'ai
eu des gens et tout même fait des bisous
j'ai demandé pourquoi les gens qui
tentent maintenant de country ont dit
c'est super c'est pas vrai ce que vous
avez fait et je me demande qu'est ce
qu'ils y font
je pense à que la vie l amour du jeu
soit
j'ai fait ce que je peux je suis pas
ignorer que je suis quelqu'un qui
consomme de la drogue et qui sait pas
facile du monde débarrassé malgré les
bonnes et julie benz est en sueur et
pourquoi tu te sens obligé de fumée
est ce que je suis ce cas vous l'a perdu
koné g pas plus perdu cournac et là
comme pour emma fut un cauchemar qu'elle
qu'on a raison d'avoir peur
il accuse arrive arrive pas tomber mais
j'y prends quand même j'ai peur quand
même pour mes enfants mes petits enfants
et mon fils
mais dis moi ça veut dire que je suis
pas je ne fais pas de costumes scolaire
la choix
ouais
ça veut dire que les gens qui fument
tous les dimanches les yeux avec la
laisse tomber moi même approché je suis
déjà prêt
attention une petite fille qui parce
qu'ils me regardent ou
c
mais qu'elle voit comme ça au moins ça
va les empêcher d'aller là oui je suis à
huit personnes à queens journée normale
tout à fait normal pour jean n'est pas
une journée normale
je me lève en bonne santé là c'est dur
je prends mon surtout ne pas être en
manque et bonjour élèves petits des jeux
nous sommes tous en fait je vois ce que
j'ai à faire sur lui vous administrative
il faire sigi rien faire
j'essaie dupuis voir comment je vais
faire là pour la gêner pour flouer matin
il est normal bien longtemps j'ai pas eu
des jaune et noir
[Musique]
à la différence de lori immi ray allen a
consommé de l'héroïne très jeune et se
retrouve seul face à cette addiction
c'est donc beaucoup plus difficile pour
elles de se sevrer elle est aussi
extrêmement dépendante des substituts
que les médecins lui prescrive depuis
des années comme par exemple le subutex
aussi appelé sub aujourd'hui me hélène
est logée par une association dont un
hôtel social
c'est là qu'elle pas son confinement et
malgré la distance elle est toujours en
contact avec lori ça va kubel et même si
mme belval bien voit jouer à chérie
comme oui je suis dans une petite
chambre d'hôtel à juguler ben c'est bien
ça il me montre les routes les lakers
une magnifique chéri du baseball charité
fumée et a bien fait de mettre les vois
tu as bien fait ma puce est apparu
détendu c'est vraiment je suis je roule
en belgique de voir quelle page a même
pas de krach ou chat là je vous le
souhaite de tout mon coeur
chérie tu jettes lycée et je t'appelle
plus tard tchalla d'accord c'est mon
bébé à moi
ma protéger moi avec je suis trop
contente ça m'a donné du courage c'est
parti à la bouche et à l'étoile s à 20
sa chance de lapurdi nervis bord le
gazon n'est pas trop chiant il pilotait
l'école aussi et puis tu habites dans
l'histoire du maire de saint paul une
bonne présentation content de ces gens
là comme pressenti mineurs tu vas faire
quoi ce matin mon âge je suis prêt à me
voir je suis en tête moi sur mon truc
moi la belle je m'adresse l'énergie
confirmant c'est quoi ton traitements
subis texte subic somme ça me fait du
seul fait de ne pas avoir des douleurs
partout une et par awa ndiaye comme ça
et ça m'a mis en marche sa mère manque
aussi les attitudes
bah oui sûrement après avec les
compliments dentiste anciens par une
sorcière
est ce que si au matra de santé station
de la mer damant et maman les gens j'ai
du mal à manger
alors franchement pays avant il va
vraiment dû faire
c'est bien pour un marché mieux la route
bah oui celui-là de toi je la quatrième
fois tu viens ici comme une fois par
semaine je viens tous les lundis et à
partir d'un traitement est ce qu'il ya
autre chose oui à la réalisation sociale
mais pour l'instant ils sont encore gigi
bas de l'hôtel on aime être là
maintenant mon plus qu'un travail
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
de nombreux sociologues addictologues
décrivent la diction comme la maladie de
la solitude
nolan n'a pas le droit de visite dans
son hôtel social mais c'est extrêmement
difficile pour elle de rester seule
pendant cette période de confinement
alors parfois son petit ami vient la
voir en secret pour les soutenir dans ce
moment difficile
[Musique]
j'en ai marre tu as vu je les marmandais
inutile et j'ai envie de travailler
envie d'avoir des cheveux et j'ai
toujours travaillé malgré que je fume
chissano
je t'avais dit au jury un diplôme
d'agent hospitalier à l'hôpital tenon
j'aimerais bien que avec michèle ou
l'inde qui soit quand même un peu plus
stable que c'est bon ça viendra moi j'y
perds pas espoir
mais la seule chose la drogue la drogue
là dedans matin midi soir a joué pendant
six mois et demi tout cela est bloqué ce
que une formalité au dessous duquel plus
de 1 300 gwh à sécher chine j'ai eu et
j'ai pas de film
[Musique]
je suis de retour
ah non ça va moins belle j'ai manqué un
peu de nous expliquer pourquoi général
sur est parce que je suis tout seul j'ai
pas le droit de visite chez pas loin
d'avoir mon fils je dis qu ils ne
croient même pas que j'ai un nom doit
habiter est ce que tu peux respecter
n c'est quoi ton parcours qu'est ce qui
s'est passé m'a moins chaud du high key
effectifs une influence et tony ce n'est
pas papa plus de famille arrivée ici je
suis tournée soit monsieur je prenais
pas et où ma maman qui n'est pas biche
là avec moi qui ne connais pas beaucoup
non plus elle a pour elle le monsieur là
il a commencé à me fait des
attouchements guerre des miss est déjà
d'un poil je vous dois l'être vers autre
idée à moi ma mère me dit que ma mère me
dit est ma mère ni même pas si tout ce
qu'elle m'a laissé tomber en haïti tu
vois moi je pensais pas l'histoire
je l'écoutais donc ça nous a bien plus
proche en aucun cas j'ai jamais pensé
que ce monsieur là il avait dans sa tête
l'idée de me coucher tard andré de
coucher avec moi c'est pas du tout ça
il a feinté réparable
je ne pardonnerai jamais jamais
l'impression que ces histoires de
beaucoup beaucoup
désolé mais c'est nous tout qui sont
comme ça tout les fusils sont pas si la
vente a expliqué les mêmes choses
alors si cela elle avait porté plainte
et j'ai pas porter plainte j'ai pas
froisser ma maman et je n'ai pas fait
remarqué ma famille et moi qui ferai un
mois que j'aime je suis fatigué tu
disais contre et ensuite a été classé ça
ouais la 12e place à la dass main
c'est dans des familles d'accueil ils
muñoz une famille italienne cuisine
beaucoup fait les airs ôta c'est que
saliver en éclats ce que je lis eu
connaissance ici pas venu les voir je ne
voulais pas les décevoir
et s'il me voyais qu'ils sachent que je
les aime beaucoup c'est des petits
moments j'ai passé qui m'a un peu
soulagé je suis parti et je décline en 5
j avais presque is a leading ouvre dix
ans sur ce même schéma est mieux vu que
à l'école je voulais pas montrer mon
wandji quitter les tre collège et à
jacques prévert à noisy le grand
une étiqueteuse images de thouars
dépend où il fait un petit capable
tu peux mon coeur tu pourras manger
killshot l'échangé j'aime bien gars
c'est clair et toi tu fumes non non non
non il n'a même pas intérêt sinon c'est
pas la peine qu'on assemble un coup
d'éclat
[Musique]
c'est
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pour
comment tu as l'impression que les gens
te calmes soir
mais pas trop
parce qu'il ne me plaisent pas je pense
que les gens ont envie les leurs alors
que je les ai pas continuer ça va et toi
tu es simplement d'une le tour des trois
toujours manip est il après toutes ces
années dans la rue qui croit toujours
je crois tu toujours quelque chose de
bon c'est quoi la solution conjointe
division de venir lorsque rencontre et
n'est pas avoir perdu bien que toujours
nous donne une confiance parce que
souvent ce sont des gens comme l'ours et
des gens qui ont quasi la confiance
parce que celui mentionné tout et que
bon notre addiction
mais c'est quand même de garder 10 on
essaie de connaître le dernier set elle
ajouté c'est quelqu'un d'important pour
les visiter
c'est soi-même dans des eaux
mauléon
les
randy mandys ont démandé
a changé laissant passer au
il a siégé à fonelle
c'est ça
la moitié des foulards solidaire
- des avocats
michalak